le chemin vers le prochain bar à whisky oh ne
demande pas pourquoi oh ne demande pas pourquoi oh nous devons trouver
le prochain bar à whisky car si nous ne
trouvons pas le prochain bar à whisky te dire que nous
devons mourir je te dis que nous devons mourir je  te dire
je te dis je te dis nous
devons dire
au revoir nous avons perdu
oh
devons dire
au revoir nous avons perdu
qui tu
connais oh montre nous l'enquête au prochain
joli garçon
oh ne demande pas pourquoi oh ne demande pas pourquoi
oh  nous devons trouver un garçon d'expertise car si
nous ne trouvons pas le prochain lapin je te dis
que nous devons mourir je te dis que nous devons mourir je
te dis je te dis
nous savons
oh
nous
devons dire
au revoir nous avons été perdus
oh tu sais  pourquoi
je vais nous montrer le chemin vers le prochain petit
donna
oh ne demande pas pourquoi oh ne demande pas pourquoi
car nous devons trouver le prochain petit dollar
car si nous ne trouvons pas le prochain petit
dollar je te dis que nous devons mourir  je te dirai
que nous devons mourir je te dis je te dis je
te dis que tu dois
mourir
euh
et
tu dois avoir des dollars